i get it i understand i understand you
know what they what it looks like
when you start putting those puzzle
pieces together you see an entirely
different picture
tonight an i-team exclusive the case of
darren mack made
international headlines a wealthy
businessman kills his ex-wife
shoots a judge and then drives off to
mexico now his son who was just a
teenager at the time says his dad
is partly innocent he talked to the
i-team's david charns
it was the biggest little thing to
happen in the biggest little city
jory mack was in high school when his
father stabbed his stepmother to death
and then shot the judge who was handling
their divorce
tonight 13 years after his father took a
plea deal
jory is talking publicly for the first
time he and his father say a new trial
would show a different story
than the one so many of us remember
one person dead one person shot and and
he's in mexico it's june 2006
jory mack is 17. his father darren
a wealthy pawn shop owner stabbed
ex-wife
charla in his reno condo it was
self-defense and all the evidence
actually corroborates that hours later
darren shoots the judge handling his
bitter divorce in child custody case
he runs off to mexico surrendering 10
days later they didn't even interview
the most important witness now 32 jory
says what happened in that garage
should never have happened at all when
you start putting those puzzle pieces
together
you see an entirely different picture
according to court records
charla came over to pick up their
daughter that's when prosecutors say
darren lured charla inside this garage
stabbing her at least six times photos
show the gruesome scene
but jury says it was charla who started
the altercation
pointing to this court order which
prohibited her from getting out of her
car
according to jury it was charla who
became violent
as he started walking back inside she
punched him in the back of the head
that's when darren who says he was
carrying a gun and a knife
fell to the ground she picked it up
pointed it at him
smiled and then pulled the trigger but
jewelry says
the gun didn't fire if she hadn't hold
that gun
none of it would have happened the gun
was never found and there was no
evidence at the scene of it firing
and darren he says threw it away
finding it the max claim would show
charla's dna
on the trigger it would prove that the
history is true
which would prove self self defense
hours after charla was killed
a sniper fired a shot through this
window hitting judge chuck weller
weller was hurt but survived dory says
his dad
an avid marksman could have fired a
fatal shot
would have been very easy if he wanted
to kill him that he just take another
shot
in court prosecutors said darren planned
the ambush
that plan was found in the defendant's
home on the defendant's kitchen table
under a stack of the defendant's
documents if you're planning on
on on doing something like this and
you've been planning it for a while
you plan not to get caught the
prosecution presented
but then a sudden plea you willfully
feloniously and without authority of law
stabbed ed into the body of charlemagne
causing her death is that correct that's
correct
he never got to tell the story jewelry
also claims his father's signature on
that plea deal was forged
comparing this signature to darren's
handwriting
i wouldn't enter a guilty plea on murder
because i didn't murder charlotte
courts have denied them all now in
federal court
darin claims his original legal team
failed him by
accepting a plea before any of their
evidence was presented
if my dad was guilty he needs to do his
time and if he's
not guilty then he needs to be set free
the question 13 years later remains
where's that gun and what happened in
that garage
we reached out to darren mack's previous
legal team they did not respond to our
request for comment
but have previously denied max claims in
court
darren mack is now 59 and serving his
sentence at the state prison
in lovelock i'm david charns 8 news now
right now on eight newsnow dot com and
inside our app
look at the evidence yourself we've
compiled a slideshow of family photos
and
images uncovered from the court vaults